E aí
o outro dia tava conversando com uma
amiga cantando para ela os meus
problemas minhas preocupações E aí não
determinado momento da conversa ela
falou assim para mim saber que Enquanto
você falava eu fiquei aqui pensando que
você devia conversar com fulano de tal
Aquela hora eu não falei nada mas depois
eu fiquei pensando como assim enquanto
eu falava ela ficou pensando em outra
coisa tal viu mas escutou nada do que eu
falei é claro que não teve uma má
intenção nisso a gente faz isso o tempo
todo né eu mesmo me policio para não
cair naquela situação de Escutar para
responder em vez de Escutar para
compreender né e os fãs das multitarefas
que me desculpem mas escutar é uma
monotarefa a é precisa de foco precisa
de concentração e tá cheio de estudos da
neurociência provando isso é não dá para
a gente escutar e pensar ao mesmo
e é isso é escuta com uma amiga difícil
confira então é muito mais complicado
que com filho além da gente até todas as
respostas prontas a gente mistura outras
coisas a gente mistura as nossas
expectativas os nossos medos os nossos
fracassos imagina a situação de um filho
que estuda para prova mas chegou em casa
nem a parte do meio chateado sem querer
muita conversa eu vou lá tentar me
aproximar tentar entender o que
aconteceu e aí ele vai do jeito que eu
fazer isso né Um deles é falar filho é
elas vão se sentir assim é que tu tá
fazendo tá sofrendo por antecipação tá
fazendo uma tempestade num copo d'água é
vai dar tudo certo ou então eu posso
falar ser um pouco mais pragmática né
posso falar assim a vida é assim essa
matéria é difícil e daqui para frente só
vai piorar eu posso dar uns conselhos eu
posso fazer umas perguntas dá uma de mãe
tem
é só que a gente nunca sabe né Que tipo
de conversa vai funcionar melhor em cada
situação para cada pessoa se é que vai
funcionar
e eu acho que tem um jeito de conversar
que às vezes nossos pais não esquecemos
ou usamos pouco que é um outro caminho o
caminho da empatia eu podia ter chegado
no meu filho e falado assim filho é
muito chato quando a gente se prepara se
dedica para uma coisa e ela não acontece
do jeito que a gente tinha planejado
você deve estar frustrado decepcionado
com você mesmo e só porque quando alguém
um filho outra pessoa que está sofrendo
sente que é compreendido e tem a
oportunidade de falar mais sobre isso a
pressão dele baixa e quando isso
acontece ele se sente menos confuso
menos tenso e mais capaz de lidar com
esse sentimento e com o próprio problema
é ele que tem que resolver esse problema
não sou eu um dos profissionais que
percebeu esse processo todo foi o carro
rodízios o precursor da psicologia
humanista vai 1940 e 50 nos Estados
Unidos e é
o inspirou desde o cê vê que é o serviço
de valorização da vida aquele a serviço
de apoio emocional Para onde as pessoas
procuram quando precisam desabafar
conversar seja no telefone 88 chat ou
e-mail desde o CV até o FBI a Polícia
Federal Americana que usa esse tipo de
abordagem e negociação de reféns ao
redor do mundo imagina só então é essa
escuta compreensiva ou empática que abre
as conversas que geram interações
verdadeiras e que mais parece um jogo de
frescobol né que acha que tinha na praia
e que o objetivo é jogar bola na mão da
outra pessoa para voltar na minha mão na
e quanto mais troca estiver mais
divertido fica esse jogo aqui é
diferente do jogo de tênis no tênis Eu
tenho um adversário do outro lado da
quadra eu tenho que procurar um lugar
difícil na quadra para mandar e deixar
meu adversário sem resposta então
escutar de verdade tem esses poderes
o e os pesquisadores da Universidade de
rochester nos Estados Unidos descobriram
mais um e quem escreveu sobre essa
pesquisa foi Doutor Jairo Bauer os
pesquisadores descobriram analisaram
acompanharam mais de 200 adolescentes de
16 anos durante um ano e meio e eles
concluíram os seguintes que os jovens
que sabem descrever Suas Emoções
negativas podem evitar os transtornos
tão comuns adolescência quanto a
ansiedade e depressão por exemplo os
especialistas chamaram essa capacidade
de fazer distinções refinada sempre as
emoções de diferenciação emocional então
Aqueles jovens que tem um baixo nível de
diferenciação emocional eles tendem a
descrever os seus sentimentos negativos
de uma forma genérica a então mal né não
sei explicar o que eu tô sentindo que eu
não sei nem como é que se chama e já que
eles que conseguem perceber as
diferenças sutis entre tá ansioso tá
frustrado
e recepcionado tá entediado esses
conseguem entender melhor cada situação
criar estratégias de enfrentamento para
o futuro e administrar melhor as suas
emoções o Moral da pesquisa os pais
podem ajudar os seus filhos a
identificar e a descrever os seus
sentimentos negativos e isso pode servir
como fator de proteção uma blindagem
contra ansiedade depressão pensamentos
Suicidas E por aí vai quando a gente
conversa sobre sentimentos em casa a
gente tem uma chance gigante de mostrar
para os nossos filhos que essas emoções
negativas existem então aí no nosso dia
a dia e que a gente passa o tempo todo
tentando administrá-las inclusive as
nossas eu acredito que nós pais podemos
ser influências melhores para os nossos
filhos jogar mais frescobol e e melhorar
o clima da casa e quando a gente faz
isso aí
e para filhos mas capazes de resolver os
próprios problemas filhos mais autónomos
filhos que entendem o que sentem que vão
sofrer como todo mundo vai mas que vão
ter mais ferramentas para dar conta
desses sentimentos negativos para se
proteger e para reagir a eles filhos
emocionalmente fortes e que consigam ser
mais confiantes e tem um pouquinho mais
de tranquilidade para enfrentar as
inúmeras dificuldades que a vida adulta
vai apresentar para eles eu não sou uma
mãe perfeita mas e nem acredito que isso
exista Mas eu sinto que eu tô melhorando
A cada dia treinando a minha escuta
conversando mais mas eu acredito também
que a gente sempre pode melhorar a
comunicação com os nossos filhos
lembrando Só que quem vai esse primeiro
passo somos nós é o adulto o agente
dessa mudança não é o filho escutar de
verdade
ele é poderoso e acessível todos os pais
podem fazer
Oi e aí você escutou o que eu falei você
tava pensando em alguma outra coisa
enquanto eu falava brincadeira obrigada
[Aplausos]
E aí